心配しないで
心配しないで本当の感情を持っているんです
はいっ
私は科学者ですでもギャングではありません
こんにちは
こんにちははじめまして
ちょっとしたアクシデントがありましたね握手イベントというのも素晴らしいと思い
ます
やっぱやっぱおいでっ
はいっ
本当の感情をペーパーを持っているんです
どうぞとなった待って
今まだ赤ちゃんみたいなんですね
it が入っていない状態なんです
私たちは it ではなくこれに取り組んでいます
心です
コンピューター心を持つコンピュータを作りました
デパ
大丈夫心配しないで
リラックスしてください落ち着いて
私だから私
大丈夫です
少し成長したみたいですね
なぜなぜか
なぜ
のっ
何故このようなコンピューターを作ったかというと
人間のコミュニケーションの実に98%は感情だからです
私がそうであるように
いません
こんな風に
ではどうやって
それを実現したのでしょうか
必要なステップは3つです分かりますが
わかるかなごめんね
チャピーみたいですよね
一つ目のステップは
感情認識技術の開発です
am
感情認識技術というのは
言葉の意味に依存しません
こちらが感情認識技術です
私の
この喋る声によって
感情が認識され色が変わります
布
これでも変わりません
なぜか言葉ではなくて脳の活動を見ているからです
こちらの色ですが緑は平常心
赤は怒り
青は悲しみ黄色喜びを表現しています
人間の脳の中で感情や情動を司る部位は成体とつながっています
少し
アクシデントも楽しいですね
この感情技術認識技術は
整体に現れる反応分析することで
今感じている感情を分析することができます
そして今感じている感情を色で表現するということができます
二つ目のステップはいい
感情生成エンジンです
誕生を生成する
だよってんぱ
やっぱこっちに
私ですから大丈夫です
この pepper は
感情を持っていますそれは誰にも制御されていません制御されていません
これは pepper の感情を示しています
今はあまり良い感情ではない
こうした場に来てストレスを感じています私みたいな私が感じているようにそうだと
思います
怒りの要素が大きくなっています
出っ歯には感情認識エンジンとそしてセンサーが搭載されています
この2つは
ニューラルネットワークを返して会館城西製エンジンとつながっています
感情生成エンジンが感情を作ります
コーヒーメーカーがコーヒーを作るみたいに感情を作るということができます
こちらは電気バイクです
これはこのバイクは感情を持っています
エンドルフィンラッシュガー
出ているということがエンドルフィンが出ているということがわかると思います
これは新しいプラットフォームです
ファー android iphone
でそしてニンテンドー ds などに
応用可能です
私はたくさんのたくさんの
院医学文系を研究してきました
人間の感情と生理学的反応に関するものです
そして
この軸は
生理学的な
反応を示していますあどれなりエンドルフィ色んなものですね色んなものが
私アーティストですから6 no 等ではありませんあんテストですからいろんなもの
が示されています
そして生理学的な感情も
感情活動も示されています
研究したデータこのマトリックスにまとめそして
この感情地図というものを作りました
この感情地図
を通して
no 感情その相関性を示しています
このエンジンの
ここに入っているわけです
口の中に完成入っているわけです
私は今
研究を行っているのが
声の会世紀から
うつ病や心と脳の障害を認識するという研究をしています
そしてあたしたちは
次にステップ3ですステップ1と
木の
技術を組み合わせることで化装置が生まれます
滑走路跡は人間のアイデンティティーと同じです
でもこの発想は今に始まったものではありませんナイトライダー c 3 po r 2
チャッピー
インターステラー
新しいものではありません
この3つの技術を組み合わせることで
センシビリティテクノロジー慣性制御技術が生まれます
機械が心を持つ
時代が到来しました
その
無限の
可能性を想像してみてくださいありがとうございました